a good hustle play by McTavish who came
back brings it into the middle of the ice
Malin got a stick on it kept it in for Rael
OK Conor drops it back and now at the line
Carlson and that high shot tipped on the
way by Rael who snuck out from below the
goal line and it's out of play who was trying
to get a touch on the puck and got probably
more of Gibson Terry looks around tried to
pop it ahead but that was sealed off good
play by Vinnie hinestrosa here's hinza tries
to stuff it around with his reach but Gibson
got the left pad in the way opening period
at Honda Center not without chances at either
end good stop by John Gibson in EST roza in
just his second game made his Penguins debut
Saturday in San Jose and had a goal and an
assist they play on zahna coughs it up and
it's it's TI to Center Ice Terry trying to
take away space for Carlson zah Horna Cuts
back throws it across the line on the right
wing Eller comes in closer Let It Go Gibson
made the stop they score zaharna throws it in
off the Anaheim net Miner from below the goal
line little bit of a miscommunication here as
Pittsburg enters the zone and you could see
no pressure really being put on penguin forward
Eller and it leads to kind of a broken play where
the puck goes off the skate of Fowler behind
the net and then it's just chopped back out
to the front it goes off the right leg of John
Gibson and trickles through the five hole over
the line they one and three when they outshoot
their opponent here's color spins it back and
laush can got it on net loose to the right at
jar color collects it but he can't settle and
shoot a battle l in back watch what jackob does
right here he's going to chop down with that puck
he gets a piece of it just catches the inside of
the Blocker of Tristan Jer Frank hangs on to it as
he brings it to the left board now high in the
zone has a poked off his stick Lookout cookout
here comes Malin looking for a trailer got it back
and a save made on Rael by Gibson third man into
the Zone Ricard Rael and that's a big time stop
for John Gibson wait Ricard Rael the word from
everyone involved in the Penguins organization
is that recel ahead zis wires it right through
the slot a swinging a Miss for Carlson and Riley
Smith tripped up penalty coming up to the ducks
rattel pounces on a two-on one with M save John
Gibson what a stop by Gibson the pass across
plays a little deeper what a great stop that was
the Ducks needed to stay out of the box they did
a real good job of it for the first half of the
game this is Pittsburgh's first Power Play of the
night it comes at 1013 in the second Malin from
below the goal line just steps out and then lome
tripped up trying to get to the rebound and that
Pittsburgh Power Play will end gensel starts back
cross the line with Malin into the middle turned
over Brent Leon splits the D short-handed Rush
pulls it in and ask the net he had some pressure
on the back side Gibson alertly able to hang on
to that here's the short-handed bid by Lisa yeah
you know he's good effort by Riley Smith to keep
pressure he's a hornet of the corner gets the puck
to Brian rust back to the line it's [Music] leang
circling out rust and a great save by Gibson as
the onetime from Rael does not get through his
former teammate it's Ricard Raquel again denied
by a real good stop by John Troy feeds the line
mnov and he play catch again movs one timer that
hit theang in front and a couple of bids won by
color and another by McTavish unable to get by
jar was that shot by mikov and actually goes
off of lat tang and creates an issue he tries to
clear it he hits his defense partner Ducks now 0
for three on the power play they get one shot on
that man ADV vanish Henrik digs it Loose Carlson
great pass still loose Henrik can't get it by jar
Adam Henrik with his head right there and he was
uncomfortable in fact that was an excuse three
time Norris winner sends it ahead Here Comes
Brian rust across the line with Crosby who flips
it right into the goal crease steer the side by
Gibson the ramp around by gensel nearly makes
it two nothing and then it's whipped wide by
Carlson it's one- nothing because of John Gibson
and look at how he stretches with that left leg
Fowler takes a hit as he pokes it back back to
Jackson lome lome pressured lost the puck high
slot Raquel and Gibson again keeps him off the
score sheet so many chances this is under the
glove but off the top of the goal P stretches it
ahead and it's redirected in by Brian rust who
gets a pass from Crosby puts it on net blocker
to Side by Gibson to the line Pon keeps it in
Crosby got it on net battled through the goal
crease by gensel gensel has had a number of good
opportunities for them and Sydney Crosby throws it
towards the net gensel got a touch on the initial
shot Shay's pass off a friendly stick but Gus
turns it back only at a cut off here comes Ricard
Rael again pulls it to his forehand and fired
it over top of the net kept at the point sent
right back through the crease and off the Stick of
Gibson out of Playard Mel with those quick hands
late first round pick at the Ducks way back in
2000 say no icing because mikov pinched off the
point Anaheim off the boards to Center Leon
gets it the rest of the way in he gets to it
he got Johnston in front to the shot Johnston
sweeps the rebound just wide good ships where
they put a little pressure on and are starting
to feed more pucks down into that crease area
Terry carries in pulls it in hit the goal post
ey off the crossbar hellberg never saw it now
a blocked shot results in Anaheim the other way
possible three on two Terry snaps it over here's
a chance firing wide was Carlson well that time
they had the center Lane Drive and it was zis
filters it below the goal line McTavish comes in
OK Conor moves it away right into the goal creas
McTavish banging away battle to the corner Eller
and Carlson Leo go after it in comes Z Center
nobody home in black and back come the Penguins
with under a minute to go gensel hits the empty
neck Carrick but this look close to offside
this is offside John now you can bet the Ducks
are going to take a look at this just threw
it to the wing and you're right I think this
plays [Music] offside and but they know already on
the Anaheim bench that that goal's coming off the
board so what Greg cronin's talking to his troops
about right now is okay you know he's telling
John Gibson when he wants him to come out of the
goal crease just shown the replay that we showed
you on the big board above Center ice and here's
the call After official review it was determined
that the play was off sides we have no goal to
play please set the clock for 56.9 Mavis trying
to draw a penalty there and he wins the draw zis
snaps his pass through the middle gensel breaks
it up minakov ahead and Fanning on getting it
deep was Carlson the Penguins just lift it back
to Center Crosby on the backand hoists it into
the empty net only Sydney Crosby and now it is
two nothing Pittsburgh 556th career NHL goal
tying him with the great Johnny buck and the
Ducks despite a valiant effort will not come
back tonight the winning streak will die at
six and the Penguins with a hard fought two-
nothing Victory this evening at Honda Center